rebecca smith and john m sh Willer are
beat reporters for the wall street
journal 24 days is there chronicle of
the enron story this talk lasts an hour
let's start with John Rebecca who was
forced to go first let's start with jaws
John mention lunch will err and he is
the ease of national correspondent I
think your your focus of coverage is
white collar crime yeah that's been the
focus of coverage with almost the last
10 years chasing around swindlers at the
white wall street journal so when you
see those pictures of those executives
doing the perp walk I think you owe me
my friends usually something with my
sources getting too cozy with your
sources well at least not handcuffed
cozy and yeah you don't get that close
right anyway let me just leave the
introduction brief like that and what
with that John go ahead okay great thank
you I'm gonna stand up i think i was
told I could do that I can't guess L so
I actually think better when I pay such
as I write a lot when I walk around but
if I do trip and make a fool of myself
don't hold against the book please or my
co-author the I'm really happy to be
here tonight it's a pleasure I'm
particularly happy to be here in the
tabard inn because 20 years ago and I
was a much younger reporter I used to
stay here whenever I could it's a
wonderful old place and I have a vague
recollection about this place although
it's long enough I could be wrong and I
could be rather the hotel or the city
but i'm pretty sure was this country
that they just have a bar downstairs an
open bar where you could actually pour
your own drinks and you're sort of write
down that you know what you wrote what
you drank and there was an honor system
and you'd pay on your bill at the end
try that was great but I was worried
about the place because everybody who
stayed here was either a newspaper
reporter or a labor activist and I
figured this is a roach insolvency for
this poor place I'm glad to see that
prognostication was wrong although we're
Beckett when she talked she can probably
tell you I had many predictions about
Enron that were completely wrong so I
have a good track record on that
the book we did I think was a little bit
different in approach than you'd
normally do as journalists we put
ourselves in his characters as you'll
see in the book and that would you know
that was in somewhat well it was one of
the first chances Becky and I had for
vigorous debate about how to do this
book we did it for several reasons and
partly because there's a pragmatic
reason that we knew they were going to
be half a dozen or more Enron books out
and that is going to be they're going to
be many of them very similar so we
thought well at least this is a
different approach to take more
importantly though we thought to have
worked a combination of some work on our
part and luck there's certainly a lot of
luck we were in a unusual position to
watch what happened we sort of felt like
we're in some ways the front seat of a
roller coaster that was on this wild and
crazy ride and that really turned out to
be a sort of fulcrum point in American
business history most of you I'm sure
remember the 90s when you know there
seemed to be no direction but up and
every wacko idea could be taken to
market and turned into a multi-billion
dollar company at least in the
marketplace and Enron that was in runs
decade the 1990s and indeed Enron sort
of was sort of viewed as one of those
companies one of those old line
companies that had somehow gotten it
gotten the message of the new economy in
the 21st century and had transformed
itself into this new economy company and
then in the space of really what is our
book title says 24 days from October
sixteenth 2001 to november eighth 2001
Enron was transformed from this paradigm
of the 21st century economy into sort of
the symbol of corporate greed excess
scandal corruption that is sort of now
taken on Enron's become the sort of word
for an entire era of actions that you
know the country sort of fines
disgusting and reprehensible and so we
wanted to try and we were fortunate
enough to sort of
go along on that journey and we were
hoping that by taking trying to take the
readers along on that same journey we
could give some sense of the excitement
but also some sense of the issues that
were being raised as this you know
rather rapid almost some credibly rapid
a time series of events were unfolding
so that's one reason we put ourselves in
as characters to this book you know what
we did journalists everyday do I mean in
some sense there was nothing really
extraordinary about what we did we got
some clues like reporters often get ours
first came on August fifteenth 2001 Jeff
Skilling had resigned the day before now
most of you probably know Jeff Skilling
he was the chief executive officer of
Anna at the time and the sort of wonder
Kent of the company he was 47 years old
he had a meteoric rise at Enron over ten
year period gone from Harvard Business
School and a partner at mckinsey &
company as he like to point out the
youngest partner the youngest managing
director at McKinsey all the weight
sometimes qualify and say well I was
tied for the youngest with Lou Gerstner
I think it was and so he gets this job
in February of 2001 it looks like he's
going to have a you know 10 15 year run
he's being lauded in all the magazines
on the cover of most business magazines
comes August fourteenth six months into
his tenure he quits and he says I'm
quitting for personal reasons of course
most people are covered corporations
figured that the only personal interest
if CEO has is holding on to his job and
so nobody really believed candlelight I
mean Ken Lay excuse me that's another
one that I have to do Jeff Skilling but
nobody really had the goods to say well
you're lying or that's not true and
nobody really knew the true reason so we
did a story that first day it basically
laid out what they said then the next
day we did a follow-up story and I was
asked to do this story and so I did what
report is often do I didn't know a lot
about the company so one I put a call
and I said can I talk to skilling again
because I figured well can't hurt you
talk to him and maybe he'll say
something more they rarely do but you
know
no and so the requests went into the maw
of Enron and started getting processed
and while I was waiting to hear back
whether there was going to be any
response I did what reporters again
often do you go over to the SEC filings
for the company god bless the SEC and it
turned out that the day before they had
made their second quarter financial
filing their so-called 10-q and so I
pulled it up from 10k wizard and started
reading through it and long ago when I
started out as a Wall Street Journal
reporter I will tell you how long ago
but it was taught to me how to read an
SEC filing quickly when you didn't have
a lot of time but you needed to try to
check something you go to the litigation
section because it's always good to know
who's suing who you know if it's a year
in state and you go and see what the
auditor statement says to see is any
qualifications tough-looking in
retrospect that the idea of Arthur
Andersen putting a qualification on
Enron is probably absurd but nonetheless
you'd go look there and then you also go
to what's called the related party
transactions section because it's sort
of the corporate dirty linen you know if
the idiot nephew gets the vice
president's job you know the Chairman's
idiot nephew or the director gets a
consulting job that's where they have to
put it in and I think one of the
problems with the reporters generally
all of us come we don't read things like
SEC filings enough because there's a
huge storehouse of information sitting
there the Internet has made it
incredibly available but you can
literally in seconds go through tens of
thousands of documents with a search
engine to find things and I it's one of
the things I don't think we do enough of
as journalists so I went through this
thing and let's read and trying to you
know pick up things and not getting much
and then I come across the rayleigh
party section this references to all
these partnerships by run by some
unnamed senior executive who the company
said partly owned the partnerships and
was doing hundreds of millions of
dollars of business with Enron I mean I
read a lot of related party transactions
sections and SEC filings over the years
and I've never seen anything quite like
that and I course my first thought okay
they senior executive quick the
partnerships two weeks ago Jeff Skilling
quit yesterday
but that's Jeff Skilling maybe that's
why he quit I thought I got a scoop here
so I call Enron up you know all excited
and I get this chief PR man he says ah
no that's Andy Fastow of course I was so
well-versed in the company by that point
I said who's Andy Fastow and he's a sort
of you know gives me this kind of tall
he's our chief financial officer like I
was a sort of an idiot child and oh yeah
we've been reporting that for two years
it's old there's nothing to it the board
approved it it's perfectly fine so I'm
deflated I think god no story there and
I still had a story to write that night
because reporters of course you know
editors we always have a story to write
that night and the deadline keeps
rolling towards you and then Jeff
Skilling calls he calls back and I got
to tell you what's the strangest
interview I ever had in my life at least
with a senior executive I mean I've had
some pretty strange interviews with
white collar criminals but they're semi
psychotic so they don't count but the
skilling was sounding like you know
usually these guys sound like masters of
the universe in complete control all
there is you know everything's assured
everything's fine and that was skilling
to a tee when he was CEO I mean he had a
reputation for self confidence that
boarded way over into arrogance you know
he once called in a critic in front of
like two or three hundred analysts on a
conference call an [ __ ] right in
front of everybody which got him all
kinds of publicity but so but this
interview was skilling he sounded
depressed I mean it was a very bizarre
interview he starts like the animals
talking to himself he's like muttering
well if the stock price is only stayed
up I could still be there and that I
don't know what he's talking about but
it's very bizarre and I finally see me
mr. skilling if the stock price hadn't
fallen Enron stock prices age they like
by then had fallen maybe you know fifty
percent like most of the market they'd
been sliding for a year and a half and I
saw ask him we mean a fee that if this
had stayed up you'd still be the CEO
because the other day before he said
personal reasons nothing to do with the
company and I asked the question this is
pause and this like little boy voice
comes back and says yeah I guess so so
we think well we got a story tonight at
least I mean the guy maybe he's a
lunatic but at least we have a story
tonight so we write that story and that
was one of our first science it was you
know why was he so obsessed with the
start
we couldn't figure that out and then we
see these partnerships and you know fast
I would quit the partnerships but they
still smell you know and partly
sometimes write things in a newspaper
because even if it's you think it's kind
of old you think it should be put on the
public record they should at least be
embarrassed enough that it's there in a
place like the wall street journal so
that they didn't just do something kind
of scummy without anybody noticing so
Rebecca and I decided about two weeks
later we had another story to do on n
run basically where Ken Lay who had been
running the company officially for 15
years although he later found out he was
like in half he was like the captain
down the state room the whole time and
never was up at the steerage we did a
story where he was going to go with the
company and we mentioned the
partnerships the so-called LJ and
partnerships for the first time now we
didn't have we didn't really know what
we had and showing what in luton
retrospect is not particularly preashea
news judgment we actually just put in
the second half of the story because
what is sticking it at the end and lucky
they didn't cut that but the that
mention was enough to get a phone call
and it's one of those phone calls that
reporters dream about getting and almost
never get somebody with inside knowledge
even better inside documents and a
willingness to talk a reasonable
rational person who actually could lay
out to us a large part of what was going
on inside these partnerships and this
person didn't everything but they had
enough to give us a beginning a road to
follow so you know these first Clues
Skilling's weird interview to mention
the partnerships led us to a second a
third bigger clue this person giving us
these documents and then we started kind
of pulling that string which is what
reporters do you know you sort of pull
along you know and we've all done it and
you know 99 times out of 100 maybe
you'll get a decent story or you get no
story but we kept pulling on this when
they kept turning into a bigger and
bigger story and there was a lot of
frustration we were you know we had a
lot of dead ends remember those first
few weeks
were we would call people and no one
wants to talk about Enron no one wants
to talk about the ljm partnerships who
were involved in them I remember talking
to a bank who wouldn't talk to me but
they wanted to make sure if I did put
their name in the paper as a lender to
Enron they wanted me to be sure to say
that they're very happy doing biz with
anyone I would like to do more and i had
to informed them that if they want to do
that she call the advertising department
of the Wall Street Journal and not me
but it was a sign of how much power and
fear and respect that Enron generated in
the business world and so we were going
along chasing down these things we were
obviously like most of American Dreams
be diverted by 911 I mean for two or
three weeks nobody really the journal I
think most other major papers did
anything to terrorism related stories we
get back to the story in early October
still trying to track down enough on
these partnerships to write a big story
but not yet having enough then Enron
announces its third-quarter learning
results on October sixteenth was really
the beginning of the 24 days it was a
classic Enron day because Enron they put
out a headline you know recurring
earnings up twenty six percent what a
recurring earnings I mean is there was
at its corporate happy talk that that
grew like mad in the 1990s what they
didn't say at the headline was down sort
of in the body the story or they also
took a 1 billion dollar charge which
gave them the biggest loss in their
history but the market like the market
often did the 90s sort of shrug that off
and Enron stock actually went up for the
day that series of events started us
writing eight we wrote our first story
about LJM the next day really there we
started putting out some of the inside
stuff thinking we better get this out
because part of that right off was due
to ljm we were starting to get worried
that other people would start picking up
an LJ m so we decided to put out what we
could prove and new and that really
started a chain of events leash for us
and I think for the company that just
picked up speed you know and then one of
the things that Enron happened to them
as they always prided themselves on
their ability to manipulate and handle
the press and they were really good at
it suddenly everything was like reversed
on so
everything they did in those 24 days
instead of working to their benefit
backfired on them you know for Ken Lay
sitting there on october2013 the
conference call basically wrapping his
arms around Andy Fastow hundred percent
self you know confidence in them next
day he's fired it doesn't exactly do a
lot for the guys you know credibility so
we try in the book to sort of go through
those events and try to sort of we hope
to carry along some of the excitement we
felt and the almost awe and wonder about
what was happening with this company
that culminated in it probably the most
extraordinary sec filing I've ever seen
on november eight where the company you
know tells the world well you can't
we're announcing four years of audited
financial statements we're taking six
hundred million dollars of loss of
renouncing 600 hours earnings we've
already reported hundreds of millions of
dollars of additional debt oh yeah we're
firing to senior officials who were you
know improperly profiting from
partnerships and it was the death knell
of Enron that and that's one reason
where we saw the 24th day and run didn't
actually go bankrupt for another few
weeks but the Enron that was sort of the
dream the Enron that had so wowed the
American investing public the American
press wall street by november eighth it
was dead and the company faced really
two choices that point it could be
bought by another company which had
tried to do with Dynegy or it could go
into bankruptcy court which it
eventually did on December second and
you know from then on Enron's future was
basically become sort of a symbol for
all that was bad in American corporate
life and so that's the rough sort of
synopsis of wit the narration of the
book and how it sort of unfolded and
I'll be glad to answer more questions
and you get Becky now but thank you
Bobby sitting for those Rebecca Smith
you're in the Los Angeles Bureau of the
washing journal and she is there she's
their energy reporter and in fact you've
been covering energy for a while right
for the wall street journal and so this
is a good time for you to be covering
energy and why don't you go ahead and
it's a little bit more about the book ok
I'm ready tripping on the wire as John
said it's a lot of fun to be here
tonight thank you so much for coming out
in the middle of a week when they're a
lot of other things you could be doing
right now John has given you kind of the
rough synopsis of what the Enron story
was for us as reporters but I think that
we're at a point in time now we are
after all more than a year after the
bankruptcy file filing when it's
appropriate for all of us to say what
did the Enron story mean to us as a
society was it just another blip in
capitalism does it have some meaning
that are there some lessons at the Enron
story in parts that we should be paying
attention to things we should have
learned from Teddy Roosevelt in his
autobiography says Americans only learn
from catastrophe and not from experience
we have here both catastrophe and a lot
of experience in emerging markets and I
think we oughta we all have learned
something from it so what might those
things being I'll give you just a few
personal reflections about a week ago I
got a copy of our book 24 days in the
mail and it was kind of exciting to open
up an envelope and actually see the
manuscript had somehow miraculously
transformed itself into a book and I had
the book sitting in the coffee table of
our home and my 12 year old daughter and
a friend of hers were over and they were
bouncing around the living room doing
various things and they suddenly focused
on the book and sat down and opened it
and they were looking at the pictures
and then out of the blue and my daughter
course has been around she's seen big
pieces of a
last year completely eaten up vacations
that never happened evenings where I was
on the computer weekends when I was at
work so she understands what the toll is
but she realized that she didn't really
understand what Enron was all about and
so she looked at me and said well what
was it that Enron did that was so bad
and you know we often in newspapers
think we were we're told we were told in
journalism school to write to the eighth
grade level now I'm in the position of
explaining to the seventh grade level
what what it was that Enron did and I
know I can't talk about share settled
costless callers I can't talk about
derivative transactions or hedging
techniques I can't talk about
mark-to-market accounting I can't reach
into this bag of tricks and pull out any
of these tools that I've become
accustomed to using over the past year
how do i explain to a 12 year old so I
said well you know it's pretty simple
Enron did a lot of really dumb things
and they never were willing to admit it
and that is the Enron story in essence
if you don't learn from your mistakes if
you don't admit your mistakes you can't
learn from your mistakes and Enron
rather than say okay we blew two billion
on broadband we blew billions on
utilities in Latin America that weren't
worth it because we were in a white-hot
heat to get in on the privatization
movement we spent a lot of money in
markets that we didn't really understand
they could never admit the mistakes
instead they devised elaborate
structures for sucking in money from
whatever source they could through
partnerships through the big banks
through any means they could and keeping
the whole thing afloat and they blew
through billions of dollars in the
process that they didn't have and
eventually it all came it all came back
at him Enron is like the proverbial
turtle on a fence post you don't know
how it got there but you know it didn't
get there alone it had it had a lot of
help in getting to where it wound up and
that for me was lesson number two for
the 12 year olds think of
out the friendships you form friends
help make you a better person they don't
take you in the other direction and if
you have friends who are really there to
make huge fee and come off of you and to
close in at the end of quarters and help
you can [ __ ] yet another group of deals
that will help you report profits for
that quarter these are not your friends
these are sick of fans I mean we have
other words for these relationships
Enron didn't realize that I don't think
these individuals realize that we see
Arthur Andersen that of course the big
accounting firm was completely destroyed
over its relationship with Enron so the
cost has been enormous both to that
company to investors to the accounting
profession to the legal profession to
investment bankers even people who had
nothing to do with this company and who
are people of you know upright character
have been sullied by it so that for me
was less than number to think about your
friendships and what these relationships
are you formed because they are
meaningful we all kind of understand
there's one incident that we described
in the Enron book I've thought about
quite a bit lately which is we describe
a scene in which ben glisan who's this
ambitious he eventually becomes the
treasure of Enron but he's described by
several people as being a kind of a boy
scout he's this shiny enthusiastic
bright energetic young guy who comes to
Enron at a fairly young age and there's
a scene with him in 1999 when they're
trying to figure out a way out of their
problems and he's in a meeting with jeff
scaling and some others and they're
saying you know we got to come up with a
structure that will help us out of a
problem we're in right now and what they
eventually come up with is something
that becomes known as the raptors their
these were four vehicles that boosted
Enron's results by more than a billion
dollars in the end and you can
understand how this happens this is kind
of the engineering problem you know we
got a problem let's fix it someone build
Thompson who does book reviews we were
talking with today and we were I was
kicking we were kicking things around
with him and he said so it's like the
guy who he's called in to fix the
counterfeiting machine in the basement
right and all he says is okay I've got a
problem I got to fix the counterfeiting
machine
in and he never thinks about what it is
that this machine is doing it is it
legal is it right and that's the kind of
a that's the kind of a cycle that Enron
was in at that meeting for the Raptors
are conceived there should have been
someone who said aren't we hoodwinking
the public through this aren't relying
to our investors should be really be
going in this direction and that doesn't
happen because they're solving the
engineering problem that's been put in
front of them I've been reading a lot of
classics in the last year trying to get
to books and I never got to when i was
younger and one of the books that i've
been reading with a lot of satisfaction
is John Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress
which may be after the Bible the book
that's been printed more widely in
English than any other yet how many of
us would think of that as a book that
business press or business people should
be reading but there's a scene in that
fairly early in the book when you know
this is basically this is a Protestant
tract about this young man striving to
reach redemption or salvation I mean
it's very theologically based and he
encounters early in his journey a man
he's heavily burdened he's trying to
stick to the straight and narrow and
he's finding it very difficult to stay
on the path and a man comes up to him
who's described as mr. worldly wise man
because of course this is allegorical
who says you know what you're doing is
way too hard and it's totally
unnecessary if you will go to that city
over there there's a man there who can
help you he is very clever about finding
solutions to problems and he will
lighten your burden and his name is mr.
legality so the young man of course
because the straight narrow is too
difficult he goes to the city and he's
trying to find the house and he finds
this is an enormous hill and it appears
that the whole here Hill is on the verge
of coming down on his heads and he's
afraid to scale it because it looks so
ominous and at that point another man
who is part of helping him you know the
pilgrim reaches his the just and
encounter Simmons says why were you
going this direction didn't I tell you
that even this way may look harder but
in the end it gets you where you want to
get that way doesn't so you know there's
something
kind of I think our forefathers and
foremothers they read these things they
thought about temptations and corrupting
influences they accepted that they were
there and we have an inclination now to
think well it's just part of what you
need to do to fit in the business world
you know so anyway to sum up I think
there's some good lessons in the Enron
story I think the more broadly we think
of them the more useful it is and that's
what I you know that's what I hope
happens one always hopes for reform and
progress and good outcomes from bad
experiences thank you we have about your
some time for questions and so I hope
those of you who have them will share
them I got one quick question before we
get started and that is as for Rebecca
and John what's the one thing the book
that you hope the readers take away with
it from it and these are through if the
reader takes away one thing from it what
do you hope that will be personal
responsibility I mean that is the reason
why we read books I mean we have to get
something useful to our own lives we
have to think about what the corporate
culture is or the agency culture or
whatever the cultural group that we're
running with what are what is it trying
to do and are we really part of it are
we helping it achieve a good and I think
there's also you know one of the most
disturbing things about the Enron story
is you know some ways how I suppose how
like how Enron was so much like so many
other companies it wasn't really a
renegade there was a recent Enron was
one of the most respected companies in
America for a decade and because it fit
in to a whole era of American thinking
and business and so I think you know we
have to sort of take a broader look at
you know what is sort of valued in this
society because in the 90s we really
started valuing fairly ephemeral things
and we really did think that there was a
free lunch and we really did think that
things too good to be true could be true
from the internet revolution part of
that I mean there is a real revolution
going on but much of what was going on a
wall street was complete Blarney and
Enron was sort of a child of that period
and so in some ways you know what struck
me most about Enron was how much it was
a product of its times and not a
renegade engine I think one of the real
strengths of both your writing writing
articles together is the focus to what
you do there's a logical progression and
the quotes are not gratuitous a lot of
articles that were written were just
lots of stuff about it
many different time I was interested
what was your process in how you decided
what you would use and not use and also
is there anything rude to it as you
didn't put in there you could she really
threw that all the book well we try to
be very careful in part because the
journals culture is a culture that's
very conservative and very careful about
what we said good it's very cognizant to
the power it has in visitor yeah and
fairness and fairness but and that sort
of goes hand in hand I mean so we I
think we tried to be very careful and we
also get remember most of the time we
were writing the early days you're still
looking in rock as a very big and
respectable company we thought well
maybe there's some strange things going
on maybe handy fast out as a deal
instead of feathering his own financial
nest but we didn't realize like the rest
of the world didn't really realize that
there was a deeper pervasive rock inside
of him it was really like a cancer fatal
cancer
so we tried to beat you know for those
many reasons very careful i think we we
can look back sometimes on our coverage
in you know people symmetry could you
said more and that story even though at
the time it seemed like we were really
kind of you know kind of pushing into
new ground it seemed to us but yeah we
said oh so we would often not put stuff
in the paper for days on end because we
hadn't gotten nailed down enough yet and
i remember one point Becky had the most
bizarre conversation at the head of
public relations remember about you know
the about whether they'd given a waiver
of the conflict of interest policy and
we had in journal we had the partnership
documents he said Andy fast out had been
given a waiver from the board of
directors for the conflict of interest
policy which you know presumably said
you shouldn't do anything against the
interest of your company
and the pr monition said yeah that's
true and then he calls back 15 20 months
later and says well no no I was wrong I
was wrong it's really the Board of
Directors looked at what he was doing at
LJ and decided there wasn't a conflict
of interest so we didn't have to get
away that's a big blatant breach of
fiduciary duty was judge not to have
been a conflict of interest but I mean
we figure and we pulled out a story that
knife in part because you know the
company was adamant about its position
and we only had it on one document you
know from from an unnamed source so we
said we got to get some more
confirmation back so we pulled it on the
story we do that on more than one
occasion you know it but there's also
sometimes what you do put in can be it
can be so illuminating and you can wind
up feeling such gratitude for example
the first story we did that talked about
the executive run partnerships ran as
they heard on the street column at the
end of August in 2001 and this is where
you just you just feel gratitude for the
journal to the journal for a hundred
years of building credibility and for
having a really wonderful national
readership because that we quoted in
there the gobbledygook that was
contained in one of Enron's SEC filings
that made no sense and we pointed out
that there was this conflict problem and
what that elicited then was his first
trove of absolutely invaluable inside
documents and what what that
demonstrated to me was there were a lot
of people inside the company who thought
this stuff is wrong what's wrong with me
that I don't out that I'm not with the
program they'd be in the meeting after
meeting where these things were being
talked about as if it was okay and they
would leave the meeting thinking I don't
fit in when they saw it in the journal
when they saw that that the DeWall
Street Journal felt there were problems
suddenly they felt it was okay to feel
what they'd been feeling and that opened
things up so that a tacked on it and
actually call somebody they needed that
confirmation because it is for anybody
inside a company a frightening and
dangerous thing to go outside the
confines of the company through to the
government or to the press and say I
found something that's not right and you
need that reassurance from someone that
it's okay okay its thermal several
questions and you were the first so why
don't you go ahead i had a jerk with in
the interest of full disclosure I I was
a reporter for The Journal for six years
she used to buy me drink so I used to
buy me drinks it's not hear back you
just mentioned the hurt on the street
column and since this is a reporting
crowd I have a question related to the
peculiar culture inside the journal and
and I know there's a lot of pressure on
reporters to get on the page one and
also a lot of editing on page one if
you're not there with the story it may
not be quite as important and I'm
curious um was there a lot of pressure
internally from journal editors if you
weren't producing a leader for page one
and also what how was competition at the
time is that that can also affect the
editors decision I don't we were not
pushed initially to produce stories for
page one in fact I don't think you know
eventually when the story becomes a big
story and all the other papers are
piling on and then you go through this
really hideous experience of packed
journalism at that point everything
changes but initially in the beginning
we had this really wonderful running
start because of the sources that were
so kind and kept bringing things out by
the time it was clear that Enron was
losing five percent or ten percent of
its value per day and that it was going
down down down and all the other papers
piled on at that point then you know I
don't think we were ever pushed
prematurely to produce anything for page
one it was more like we were just trying
to keep up with the pace of events
themselves there was I mean when we got
those first set of documents there was a
recognition that it could be a big story
that we still had a long way to go
because it was basically some documents
and a bunch of fairly explosive
allegations from this source about what
was going on inside of Enron but we had
no confirmation so we merely talk to our
editors and they were interested in a
possible page one piece and it's Christy
knows from being at the journal that
sort of the
ultimate place to get is on the front
page of the journal and one of those
what we call leaders and that's partly
explain one thing you have more space
you could tell a bigger story because
you simply get more column inches and
you also just use and usually get more
readership too although the herd gets a
lot of readership as well which is in
the third section of the paper so we
were working with the hope in those
first few weeks after we first got these
documents which really be like September
early September through early mid
October with that kind of hiatus because
of 911 and actually Becky and I had a
little debate although not much on the
16th when the earnings came out because
I still was hoping having been at the
Wall Street Journal longer there i had
my office had more of an attachment page
once twice and you know thinking well
should know should we throw what we have
into this night story should we try to
hold it on the hope that nobody else
picks it up and becky was you know
pretty strongly we should put it in
tahoe and and our bureau chief was the
same and i really i did agree with them
all I just had some trepidation thinking
maybe we could hold it and you know get
a bigger story so we decided to throw
everything in but no there was no
pressure in that sense oh you got to
hold it for page one of anything you
know they wanted to once it became clear
that things were starting to break they
said get stuff in the paper as fast as
you can we'll keep giving you space you
know and when it gets on page one if it
does it'll get there but don't worry
about where it goes just get stuff and
as far as the competition Becky as Becky
mentioned we were fortunate you know
having that source those documents the
leads that produce gave us a big lead
because nobody else was looking at that
stuff then and even on the you know the
16th when they came out with his record
loss the press didn't much you know
react to it the New York Times did a you
know a piece about the loss the post you
know how to round up like a
one-paragraph mentioned in a round up
the LA Times which is a refined
newspaper and did you know a lot of
great coverage of business in California
didn't even do a story which was a
little odd because Enron had been this
you know pretty big thing in the
California electricity crisis but they
didn't actually do a story the next day
so there wasn't a lot of interest
in Enron as of October sixteenth in the
press beyond the kind of normal
corporate coverage and so we were lucky
in that sense that we had the field we
had a lead and we also had the field to
ourselves for the first week or so you
know and in a story that goes on for
months and months that lead evaporates
because when you get enough good
journalists chasing a story you're not
going to keep the lead they're going to
start beating you on stuff it's just
inevitable the thing about Enron of
course is that the thing collapsed
really in 24 days so the other the other
guys and women had a hard time gearing
up in time to really you know by time
this happened it was just so sudden
before you started talking about the
ephemeral nature both Enron and the and
the tech bubble that it was on my mind
to ask you if there was a connection
because they did happen pretty much or
the tech burst pretty much happened
right around the same time and the thing
that was going through my mind is this
smoke and mirrors thing about being
compensated with something that isn't
really compensation and selling
something as Enron did that you don't
really have and it all and now fast out
brings up a different piece of it
because he's to my mind the evildoer the
one who was out for himself and I didn't
I didn't conceive of skilling in that
way though maybe he was but I guess the
lesson that I'm looking for is where is
there somewhere else are there other
stones that we should be turning over
our where are some other areas where the
whole concept behind it is so ephemeral
that
maybe there's another good story there
well that's a good question and you know
as we know that there are thousands of
these so-called special purpose entities
out there in the corporate world you
know these are these off-balance-sheet
entities that have been around for a
long time and can often be used in very
legitimate ways but again it's you know
it's the question of how you start using
them in what degree and Enron kept
getting more and more aggressive
creative until they finally is like the
old line you know they kept moving the
line until they found the line is 38
feet beyond the cliff and you don't know
I mean one of the things i think that
was in the legislation last year was to
put i think the sec christina bella
tommy was required to do a survey of the
s the use of SP es in corporate america
how extensive they were and give sort of
a sense of what they were we're trying
to say i think people are still trying
to figure that out but there may well be
in some of their some very outrageous
thing some very you know at best
ephemeral things let me get a nice way
to put it
before my question I wanted to tell
Rebecca as someone who does what you do
and is waiting through big pogroms
progress I think I know that the term
muckraker was coined by Teddy Roosevelt
at the 1908 and all your orders got like
no the course darling of the Longworth
office building that's where the term
muckraker came from Pilgrim's Progress
the man with the muckraker who was
oblivious to his heavenly gift but my
question for both is to what extent were
their efforts to influence you in your
reporting once you got underway either
by Emma honor by people representing
Enron or to what extent were forces
influencing you such as the competitive
media that interfered with you telling
the best or you could tell the quickest
and best way you could tell him whether
they were calculated to do that or not
you know my my gut answer is there
weren't I mean I think for one thing
well I think you would expect for
example pushback from Enron wouldn't you
I mean that's what I would expect but I
think Enron was so dazed by what was
happening to it that they never did
launch a good defense they were without
the master magician Jeff Skilling at the
time the story broke Ken Lay was not up
to the task of explaining why the
company had gotten to the place that had
clearly Andy fast L shortly after this
starts is gone and there's a point in
time where we now know one of Ken Lay
senior aides calls fast Alan says we're
getting killed by the journal we need
some of your documents and he says I'm
sorry I've resigned my positions from
LJM to I no longer have them so here's
the company being caught in positions of
not having the documents it feels it
needs to understand let alone defend
itself so I'd say we never got the push
back from them um I never felt any did
you from anybody particularly just you
just me
the the Enron actually had a very
unusual and odd response when we first
started doing this which was they stone
walls now if you know Enron that's that
is very unusual because they really
prided themselves on their ability to
handle quote-unquote the media and
skilling of course was the master
handler because he you know he would
does Becky can tell you about it I just
bury you in fact I'd Xin assertions and
you know you don't get that what kind of
idiot are you you know hi and so we sort
of expected that that Enron would bury
us in helpfulness which was of course
not helpful and we put in requests as
you know we got close enough to sort of
think we had some stuff to ask for an
interview an rod did an unusual thing
then they asked us for written questions
and of course that's a whole big issue
in journalism no do yet what how do you
deal with written questions and Becky
and I had an argument about that or at
least a bit of an argument but we sent
question Punch and Judy day for us all
right I actually won that argument
wouldn't miss it so I remember it but
the so we set the questions and the what
you know we are fully it was actually
less informative than whatever you put
in there SDC file
Becky was quite a sort of upset that
we've done all those questions said I
told her I felt we tipped our hand too
much that it was unnecessary that
sending them something less than a
roadmap of everything we knew about am
in the form of these questions something
less than that might have elicited
something but to me it was actually in
some ways the most powerful statement
they could have made because expecting n
run to come in various with information
and assurances it all back when they
came back and said nothing that perhaps
more than anything else up to that point
told me there was something big going on
inside of Enron something so big they
were afraid to talk about Joe
interference or what have you um where
you can put this period of covering the
story were you completely insulated I
guess you are generally completely
insulated from the op-ed section of the
journal I know they're considered very
separate but I would think that the
op-ed section didn't have quite the same
take that the news operation did was was
their internal tensions there any we are
no reasons there's a complete bar all
believe me most extensive contacted
editorial pages I used to play Melrose
in the New York bureau I used to
regularly play racquetball with it one
of the editorial page writers and used
to take a lot of satisfaction from the
team lead eating cookies yeah but you
know the journal has a huge wall you
know I actually don't think the I think
we get to her Paige people would deign
to talk to us because they I think they
think we're uneducated or
but the sono there was none of that
although I must say for the editorial
pages defense they've been fairly hard
on the whole Enron effect they certainly
been very critical of the banks
particularly morgan and citibank as
these sort of almost corrupt enablers
that you know allowed Enron and then
they were vital to Enron building the
financial artifice that it did they fed
to have it and he said here the other
patients is holiday that they believe in
free market capitalism but they also
believe that if you break the rules if
you lie and cheat that you the market
should should punish you you should be
pummeled and in you know extremists we
should actually have to call in the
government that's a pretty extremist for
the throw and put him in jail so you
know the journals editor patient i think
my sense was offended by what happened
at Enron and with some of those big
corporations yes
crisis in the California spot market for
electricity play in your investigation I
mean did you see that as a clue that
something was wrong given and Ron's role
in the California market or were you
looking just at the stock prices later
on the prices went crazy from yeah I
mean my job is national energy reporter
for The Wall Street Journal so that
previous year in fact Jeff Skilling
resigns in August of 2001 the entire
earlier well from may of 2000 until that
point I was just completely wiped out
and dominated by the california energy
crisis and I we both live in California
so we experienced firsthand and I'd been
covering energy and in california since
1995 so i watched the state put together
its deregulation plan so certainly we
were very much aware and john and i
first began working together when the
electricity crisis became two largest
story for me to handle alone so
certainly very aware of Enron but of
course is as you know there was a lot
about in Ron's involvement in that
market that was unknown until the death
star get shorty and all those and many
other memos came to light when Enron
waived its attorney-client privilege so
I was I really until we had that
documentary evidence I found it
impossible to believe that Enron and
some of the other traders were doing
what they were doing it is so morally
reprehensible to me to think that people
would do what they did just regardless
of the consequences in state of
California I don't understand that it
was made before that the Enron story is
saw the Watergate story for the business
press Watergate stimulated a lot of
interest to young reporters to go into
the news business and uncovered
government which seemed to be reformed
and transformed for a while but there
was but there was iran-contra and now we
have another story on why do we go to
war in Iraq so there's a lot 32 report
Rebecca you mentioned personal
responsibility is that story over now
with Enron or should young reporters go
into the business press because there
will be down the road more in Ron's
what's your take on the street these
days well I think they're always will be
more stories of graft and corruption I
mean that is part of the human
experience right and I don't think you
go into journalism I mean I understand
there were a lot of went in
post-watergate I mean I think you go
into it because it's a it's interesting
every day brings you something new I
mean it's a stimulating career it's fun
it's socially useful I think those are
reasons enough to go into it um I mean I
think given human nature the basic
structure of the marketplace you know
Enron partly did what it did because the
marketplace likes almost demands in ways
we would like to see I was like to see
happy results you like to see growth you
like to see so you know like this
quarter fifteen percent above the
year-ago quarter those demands don't go
away they're still there and you know
they've been those kind of things that
the death through go at least most of
the last several hundred years you can
go back to them the tulip mania sixteen
hundreds in Holland and the South Sea
Bubble England in 279 you can pick your
century and you can find your schemes
and scams and frenzies because human
nature you know doesn't change as fast
as technology we just do it faster now
like a bigger scale but the motives are
still there they're still out there
right now the marketplace in corporate
America's have a big kick in the head so
there's a lot of you know hangover but I
don't think you know investment banking
is one area i think has not been
reformed I think there's they're getting
by almost getting off scot-free at this
point their pet throwing some money in
that's not been touched really i don't
think in fundamental ways we have time
for a few more questions and stir on the
back
the event you cover in 24 days were just
so fast and furious and your book takes
a kind of a retrospective look but going
forward where do you where do you see
the story involving more more
specifically and it seems pretty clear
that Ken Lay was a mia will know nothing
or was he and Jeff Skilling clearly
nobody believed on August fifteenth that
he was quitting for personal reasons
which which led you on your hunt where
do you see the story going the future
will we will we see well we see
culpability beyond and faster one thing
we've learned from earlier periods like
the insider trading scandals in 1980s is
it can take prosecutors years and years
but these cases together and those cases
were probably not as complicated as
Enron the other challenge with Enron is
if you bring a case you have to be able
to explain it to a jury that's very
challenging I mean they nearly lost the
obstruction of justice case against
Arthur Andersen they really want it on a
fluke so I think they're being extremely
painstaking they don't want to bring
charges against Jeff Skilling or Ken Lay
and lose and they've learned that it it
pays to be cautious I don't think we're
at the end I'm sure there will be more I
mean I feel there will be more charges
whether it will include those two
gentlemen or not I don't know but you
know one of the perversity and the Enron
story of census we may look back on it
and find that there's lots of things
we've learned about that you're going to
that should have been a crime but it may
not be a crunch which is one of the
things that the prosecutors running into
as they're doing their investigations is
what you could call the expert defense
when Enron had outside accountants they
had outside lawyers passing on vast
amounts of this business and saying it
was okay it could construct this legal
argument or this accounting argument and
you can do that and you know what we now
see is people are Arthur Andersen looks
like they would be saying yes almost
anything so the fundamental job of the
outside auditor that was set up or was
to sort of be a representative and help
protect the public have to be a break on
corporate behavior it looks like Arthur
Andersen basically completely fell down
in that but it gives a lot of the Enron
executives on a lot of their
transactions tough to say well how can
you shot sad criminal intent if my
auditors told me it was legal you know
what they've so far got nandi fast
though they've invited them on a more
traditional fraud charges where they're
saying you didn't tell the auditors
crucial information you lie to your
board of directors about this or you
cheated some of your partners and one of
the partnerships put money in your son's
bank accounts yeah so those are more
garnish riety fraud cases it will be
interesting to see if they can ever sort
of pierce that experts defense or
whether they try but we may end up
finding that one of the greatest lessons
of Enron is you know that the failure of
the internal systems assistance we'd set
up to kind of help you know ensure
honesty in corporate be
you just fell down on the job and may
let some of these people off one thing I
wanted to dis mention whether 24 days
becomes the equivalent of All the
President's Men or not I think it's the
reason that there's so much attention
drawn to them it's an example of a story
that from a reporter's point of view is
unbelievable and almost too good to be
true that it keeps going and unraveling
and raveling and I think we've mentioned
before how this stands up long-term many
young people today are really riveted by
the Enron concept because it's an
example there's a lot going on we don't
understand but this is really wrong and
you're some specific things that were
wrong and it's something that is
difficult as is you can grab onto and
the strength of your reporting and 24
days is it explains how you try to
unravel that and how you follow a story
that is unbelievable and I think in that
way I think that's how the book can
really have an impact in terms of you
have journals you know and you asked a
question earlier about how to old
reporters cover things differently than
young reporters and one thing I have
learned over the years after more than
25 years at this is there is care and
feeding of a story I mean you really you
really can keep feeding the beast in a
lot of ways and keep the information
coming and you can sustain a story I
think much better as an older reporter
than as a younger one you you learn to
pace things a little differently because
you want to keep it moving and
progressing
in terms of using what you were reported
prompt stuff to come out lot more
sources to come up with more information
well the best was the hurt on the street
I mean that was like it works so well it
was so gratifying haha the see nothing
you can think of it was modestly
embarrassing but we sometimes got tips
when we missed something but yeah the
second day after the earnings we Enron
had done a classically Enron thing that
has a bad news they had to write off I
had to reduce their shareholders equity
by 1.2 billion dollars because of the
LJG I'm partnership and rather than sort
of as some people suggested put a filing
with the SEC to just announce that or
even putting it at their earnings press
release which other people recommended
Ken Lay decided to mention it one quick
sentence in their conference call they
have a record with the animals at the
deer anything sort of like look it's
actually so they could say well I said
it and you know everybody practically
missed it and so we missed it from the
first day story and a helpful short
seller always very helpful people called
us up and said hey you idiots you missed
this big story and so that night we did
a story about the 1.2 billion dollar
equity reduction which we got credit for
breaking some new news even though we've
missed it the first place and actually
it turned out the deep the actual equity
reduction itself was not nearly as
important as the fact that people
started perceiving that they hidden and
the act of seemingly hiding it was far
more damaging to Enron it ever would
have been just announcing which again
goes back to this notion that's up to it
if you got a problem just admit it and
say it you know deal with it because
emraan found that you know by hiding it
sending oh my god
so they hiding oh my god and he lying
doing at one point to believe this but
this so pretty Santa's real money right
yeah and then there that story brought
on another set of documents somebody
else called well I got more for you so
it sort of started feeding on itself and
you know you never know I mean you
sometimes write a story and goddess is
going to have a gigantic impact and it
falls off into a cliff and you never
hear from them again let's take two more
questions and then I hope that you'll
stick around afterwards and if you want
to ask them more questions later please
do so so two more questions let's get
you that's what's doing three more you
then you then you know resources who
drop information to you or drop a dime
for you are they generally people who
are just offended by the dishonesty or
are they looking for something on their
on their own even though they wouldn't
might be unidentified sources and you
know you didn't get it from me but
here's here's the thing are they looking
for some gratification some evil
gratification of their own we have both
you know most people have you know their
motives for calling the press know very
some people are really just you know
good citizens and offended most people
have somewhat face your motives you know
they want to make money that really
pissed off at somebody you know they
want revenge you know and you've got you
have to realize that you know and my
ears reporting I started kind of
conclusion that in some ways person's
motives are less important than the
quality of their information and I've
got really rotten information from
saintly people and it's no good to me
because you can't print really rotten
information and the other hand I've
gotten really useful accurate
information from people i wouldn't spend
i wouldn't stand the same side the
street with
so in some ways you start ending up
trying to evaluate the information
almost more than you're evaluating the
person their motives because on one end
you never really know the motors it
helps and we've certainly felt more
comfortable with our original source
that both of us felt that this person
really was trying to do the right thing
you know we didn't know for sure but
that's the sense the person never really
overstated stuffed person you know they
didn't start going off in diatribes
about you know Andy Fastow and the CIA
and you know kind of things just
sometimes get from people who are
obsessed so that helped but that
wouldn't have been enough by itself are
sore throat I always care about
motivation I really do because I don't
want to see the newspaper used so I'm
always defensively you know that's why I
like short sellers mmm don't like them
can't help it don't like them not enough
reporters read the financial statements
all the time and do you think in
hindsight that if reporters had read the
Enron financial statements more
thoroughly before all this happen that
they they would have figured out these
things and what they just so obscure and
odd that and made up no one wanted out I
think a lot of it was so obscured odd
that reporters probably couldn't have
deciphered a lot of I couldn't decipher
and but you know sometimes do wonder
they were putting out mentions of these
LJ and partnerships for two years mm you
know prior to august two thousand and
one so you wonder if somebody had said
you know run across it a year earlier
and put something out would you know a
source of call it could have just you
know put something in the paper and it
dies you know stories do have their
moments sometimes you do a stack same
story you know now nothing happens you
do that same story six months later a
year later all hell breaks loose so you
don't know but I think you know the job
of a journalist isn't so much to
necessarily say i'm gonna i can do this
or that your job is say okay here's
something that looks like it's news hmm
I found it I'm gonna put it out there
and see what happens a lot of times
nothing happens that's part of the first
of journalism well as a beat reporter
and when the story broke the question
was where was the press where were the
beat reporters well I'm the beat
reporter for The Wall Street Journal gee
what an uncomfortable position to be in
a lot of ways because it was a question
why didn't I read that why didn't I
asked questions about it and I didn't
and the answer is I get dozens and
dozens of sec documents every month and
I in a lot of respects you find what you
look for I mean I'm always so buried in
these documents trying to find things
that so so it's kind of a Mia culpa for
me because I wish I'd found it and asked
a question although my gut says to me it
would have led to nothing they'd have
tied me in knots or they'd have given an
explanation that would have basically
you know it would have led to nothing
that's that's my conviction but we'll
never know I could person and I'll
always wonder Rebecca is no one
willingness to breathe deep
and impenetrable doc she read things
about the California tea prices I fairly
wanted to lift up Sarah last question
yeah I just wanted it for the journal or
any other major publication has survey
business to see what had been the effect
of Enron and all they will calm other
stories on their curricula but imagine
it some of them at least raised emphasis
on business ethics I feel interesting
question I don't know the journal doing
it I don't think we surveyed it but I
think there's a general perception that
certainly the MBA students now are
spending more time talking about ethics
then they have in a long time I know
Rebecca certainly J schools are good you
got invited to one who's the j-school or
b school for event I got invited to the
UC Irvine business school they had a
whole course they did on Enron five or
six part course on Enron I don't know I
was just you know one instance but other
schools might haven't I found there was
a there was a very big turn out that
people seem very interested in the
issues raised and the whole subject of
corporate governance plan and ethics and
also that I found at UC Berkeley and
Boston University a great interest in
accounting that was never considered
such an exciting area we'll both for
business journalist is one of the things
we're doing at the American person
institute is helping journalists
understand accounting in these areas but
also people who studied business in a
little different way and maybe even some
there might be a few other can lays out
there who didn't look as closely at some
of the areas that they might have so
accounting is one of the more popular
courses around the country these days
and I'm sure just sort of effect
everybody's realized important Rebecca
John Angie thank you very much and thank
you and hope you stick around for more
questions afterwards rebecca smith and
john m sh Willer won the 2002 gerald
loeb award for their newspaper coverage
of Enron 24 days is published by Harper
business for more information go online
to Harper Collins com